And um
I would now like to invite Lea Miller to
stage. She actually has a background in
philosophy, but she's been doing
knowledge graphs and the semantic web
technologies for quite some time having
a background at Amazon and then at
Bloomberg. And right now, um you're lead
ontologist at SAP.
And um we're looking forward to This is
going to be for those who are interested
coming from the LLM space and interested
in well
what how could knowledge graphs improve
here? This is your talk. This is going
to give you some practical pointers on
that and yeah, thank you, Lea. The stage
is yours.
Can you hear me okay? Is it close
enough?
Can you hear me?
Yes. No. Hello. Is this better?
I will keep it up as high as I can. Uh
okay. So, thank you all for coming. Um
I wanted to talk about, hopefully,
uh knowledge graph creation or
construction. So, I think this is a
uh a big theme um and it's a uh
a part of this process of uh all the new
um LLM
uh innovations with graph rag or
text-to-query. So, everyone uh even even
before that, but especially now,
developers are coming to our team
uh asking about uh knowledge graphs and
how to incorporate it into their LLM
pipeline for whatever they're trying to
solve.
And so, I wanted to talk about this bit
of it that's uh still a very We're
trying to find ways LLMs can help um
streamline the uh creation of knowledge
graphs, but it's still very much a
uh opaque or
uh
cumbersome process and it requires
people, human in the loop, and all that.
So, I just wanted to go through very
high level and very as encompassing as I
possibly can be without uh
using any tool. So, it's tool agnostic.
It's um use case agnostic. Uh it's not
saying which type of graph you should
use, if it's labeled property graph, uh
RDF, or if it's um working at Amazon and
Google, they have their own graph
structures and query languages, and I
think a lot of other other companies do.
So, it's not making a call on the type
of graph, either. It's just going
through
uh just the the process, what goes on,
and then what bits can kind of be
uh automated, and what's still very much
a manual process.
Uh so, first, I'll go through
uh what is an ontology, and what is a
knowledge graph, and there are many
definitions, so we'll uh I'll present
what I'm going with today. Uh and then I
will uh
look at a little bit just how I'm seeing
how knowledge graphs and ontologies can
help LLMs. So, I'm trying to be very
specific, not necessarily all the
benefits, but just looking at concretely
what you can add to your LLM pipeline,
the information to enrich it, to get um
more accurate responses from your um LLM
solution around your enterprise data, in
particular. So, this is very much around
focusing on enterprise data and
structured data, I think principally.
Uh then we'll go into the
uh knowledge creation uh knowledge graph
creation process, which is a data
modeling process. And we'll look at an
example from our open data portal at
S&P, called donnel.org.
And donnel stands is a short form for of
uh data unlocked is donnel.
And so, we'll take that example from
from there, and go through all the
steps. Then I will touch on uh
challenges uh that I that I faced as a
um an ontologist data modeler at uh
these organizations, and then the tips,
and the spoiler alert is it's all about
AI-ready data first before
thinking even about
knowledge graphs too much, but just the
general
getting your data AI-ready is the main
message here.
So, what is an ontology? So, in
philosophy, do you have any
philosophers?
Philosophy background, anyone? All
right.
So, the the concept dates back to
ancient Greece. So, we've got
we've got Plato, the the older gentleman
on the the left, and Aristotle
on the on the right there.
So, it later becomes a branch of
metaphysics within
within philosophy, and it's just about
looking at how we should be categorizing
things, how things are related, how we
should be talking about existence, and
it's a very fun and
very deep field
in philosophy. So, that's where that's
coming from. In computer science, it's a
formal representation of knowledge. So,
it's something very specific, and it's
defining concepts, relationships,
properties within a specific domain, and
it is machine readable. So, it's
something very very specific in computer
science.
From our perspective, so from a data
modeling perspective, an ontology is a
schema for a graph structure, or more
specifically, a knowledge graph.
A knowledge graph is a like a graph, but
it is semantically enriched is the best
way I can think of to describe it, where
we're being very explicit about
relationships between entities, and
we're just adding an enormous amount of
information about all of these entities
as opposed to just the general graph
node edge structure.
And then some common applications,
uh Knowledge Graph being the most famous
um but other uh use cases include
recommendations. So, IKEA uh will be
they'll be presenting that in the
the other section. Uh also voice
assistants use um
uh knowledge graphs as well. Social
networks and data catalogs, they have a
semantically enriched data catalog and
they're using uh this graph technology
to do that.
So, a few ways and it's cutting off a
little bit. Sorry about that. Um
uh So, a few ways that I'm seeing, so
when I'm working with developers, they
want to
either in the context of text to query
or text to sequel, text to sparkle, so
that's a really big thing right now,
especially uh when it comes to
enterprise data. This is what they're
trying to add in their
um
LLM pipelines. And so, I'm uh just in if
they have a, you know, traditional uh
config that they're just trying to add
in uh this metadata for for their their
enterprise data to to get more accurate
answers, it's kind of separating out
what you can put in there as opposed to
the additional uh information you can
add leveraging a knowledge graph. So, if
you have a use case um where you uh you
want to have um
more scalable language tagging or
uh lineage or um
inferencing, that kind of that kind of
thing, go with a knowledge graph.
And I see uh two ways here, so there's
more. This is not an exhaustive list at
all and I'd love to talk with with you
all about this uh sometime after. Uh but
there are two ways that I'm seeing uh
how knowledge graphs or ontologies are
helping. So, one is the enriched
metadata side of it, that's um
using the domain uh ontology mapping to
your actual data elements being put into
the pipeline to give the LLM more
information
uh or completely converting your
original data structure into a knowledge
graph and using that. So, there's a lot
of studies showing um
that uh
it's uh
performing better if you're going with a
text-to-SQL or sorry, text-to-SPARQL
over text-to-SQL
um pipeline. So,
those are the two ways I'm seeing it.
Uh
So, yeah. Now, we'll go into the data
modeling process. So, very high level,
what's happening uh in an enterprise
setting.
Uh we start with our requirements. So,
that's the product owner. Uh all of
these things here in the requirements
actually help shape our data modeling
later on. So, it's really important to
have
um those product requirements, the use
cases, the features that are needed.
That'll actually help with the design
later. It's really important to have
uh that up front. Uh then there's a
discovery phase, and this is where the
uh subject matter expert is very
important.
Uh where we're working with the subject
matter expert to uh come up with a
conceptual model, to create a more
detailed data dictionary. Uh at this
point, we're already looking at source
data. So, we're not going to do data
modeling without looking at actual data.
Uh and we're coming up with competency
questions that we're going to use to
test our model later on. Then we're in
the design phase. This is where the
ontologist knowledge engineer or data
architect, sometimes they're called data
modeler,
uh is going to
uh take everything before it and create
a logical model. Uh there's going to be
some mapping and to the physical model.
Uh and then we move over to
implementation. And these all kind of
work everyone kind of works together
across the bottom is what I'm I'm
showing here.
So, we will first we'll start with the
an example from Dunel. So, please visit
dunel.org to see we've got uh tabular
relational representation
and RDF representation of the same data.
So, you You kind of
see an example of what it looks like in
both. We also have a
CS VW metadata document for each of the
data sets, so you can see what that
looks like.
Um
and the kind of data that we're working
with is
uh around it's so we've got company
data, price assessment data.
Um
we've got units of measure data. So, a
lot of reference data sets that are
really helpful to customers just to use
generally, so they're they're linked to
their specific data sets if they need to
uh have additional reference data to
enrich their their product.
Um
So, if we take a first take first look.
So, the the first step is the conceptual
model. This is part of the uh design
phase.
And uh I want to call out the conceptual
model. There are other artifacts that
you produce
uh during this design phase, but I think
this is a really important one to uh
it's a an excellent tool to go into
these uh sessions with your subject
matter experts to sit down and just come
up with your uh what are the main
concepts in this domain? How do they
kind of roughly link together? You don't
have to worry too much about specific
data points or if they should be
entities or uh
uh
data type properties or object
properties yet. You don't You don't care
about any of that. You just want to
understand the domain and uh this is
where maybe LLMs can help as part of a a
domain research or uh
uh
an entity extraction or other uh
tried and tested NLP techniques that uh
Paco in that talk yesterday goes over.
This is a great time to to do that. I
think the developer and the uh
ontologist can work together on
providing that um
that really helpful information in those
conversations with with the SMEs.
So, this kind of this takes a long time.
I think this is a uh
an iterative process that you aren't
going to get right with just either only
talking to SMEs, not looking at your
data, or only kind of doing these
automated
um
uh
techniques to to build it. You have to
kind of combine the two.
Uh then you're going to go to you're
going to create your logical model, and
this is supposed to be structure
agnostic, platform independent. So, you
don't you're not making any calls yet if
you're going to make a graph or
relational database or
use a certain type of graph that it
doesn't matter. You just want to now
with each data point, you want to be
able to classify it as what it is.
Uh so, the looking at your data is very
important. You're you're going to cover
all of your enterprise data here.
Uh and you want to adhere to
or agree on the diagramming standards
that you you want to use here. Uh so,
UML is a is a great one to use.
Um one caveat for knowledge graphs, it's
really important to
uh
to create your object property or the
relationship between entities or objects
is really important.
Uh
because your those are going to be
explicit in your graph later.
Um
So, next we've got the physical model.
So, this is where you're going to make a
call and based on your logical model, a
lot of it translates pretty quickly and
easily over into
uh your your physical model. So, at the
top we have an example of a
an ER diagram and a SQL DDL
uh schema. And at the bottom we have the
same the same data in a an ontology
diagram. And a the actual RDF file
turtle serialization. Um there are other
serializations as well for
uh for RDF
uh we've seen, like JSON-LD.
Um but this is the Turtle serialization.
And then you're going to want to map
between these two if you're going to go
with that first option of just sending
in enriched metadata. So you'll want to
map those domain entities to your
um your uh tabular entities or your data
elements.
Uh and sometimes this is uh so you can
do this with There's a lot of tools out
there to to do this. You can also create
your own to do this kind of
um
uh for instance, R2RML you can use.
There's tools that do that to help
automate this process of mapping to your
data elements.
Uh
however, there's still a lot of manual
intervention with that because our data
is quite messy and a table a lot of it
is denormalized usually and your your
table isn't going to necessarily always
equate to the uh domain entity.
Uh there's going to be several entities
within a table and you have to tease out
which attributes actually apply to which
uh domain entity. So there's still a
manual process even if a lot of it can
be quickly mapped.
So putting it all together, uh if you go
with this this first route where we're
we're not converting our data structure
into a graph, we're just sending
additional uh enriched metadata,
uh you're going to send your ontology
and your mapping to your data elements
to inform the LLM uh which table they
should be looking at uh for specific
questions that are uh more related to
the the the text uh question that you're
uh that you're asking the LLM. And then
if you're converting it into
uh knowledge graph, you're going to
somehow um
uh hook this up. So this is more the the
graph rag solution uh and convert your
your data into um a knowledge graph and
that can be done through virtualization
or it can be actually materialized. But
just um you're going to send in your
your ontology and your knowledge graph
there.
So, challenges that I see
um
So, the just the the complexity of
enterprise data is is enormous.
Uh there's
uh we're working with a lot of
uh
tech debt or a lot of different views, a
lot of tables, especially in relational
database land that are almost identical.
And the maybe your LLM is is having
trouble deciphering which one to query
because they are they are so um
there's just a lot of mess, a lot of
duplication.
Um and so, we're we're having to deal
with with that um as we're building a
knowledge graph, which is already
um
uh
much more complicated than some of the
examples, including the one I've shown,
um that is very they're very simple
examples that work really well with
these automated uh solutions. But, the
actual nature of our enterprise data is
is just much messier.
Um the automation versus manual uh
effort here. So, I uh you can
automate uh
several bits of this whole entire
process, but you can't automate the
whole thing. It's just a it's a
combination of this manual effort and
consulting uh
uh various SMEs.
Um and then I'm seeing just a lot of
sparse metadata documentation. So,
that's something that uh
we could improve upon. So, anywhere you
go uh
I'm I'm finding that we just didn't
document that or just updates haven't
been documented, so it becomes obsolete.
Uh we're not using uh data catalogs or
there's a missing feature. It's not
capturing lineage, and that's something
we really need.
Uh or we're not looking at the source
data, and we're building on top of uh
these different views, like I say, and
we're not actually fixing some of the
optimization we could um we could
actually addressing the source data
first.
Okay, so some of the the tips.
So
it's the whole theme is to make you all
of your data AI ready and a lot of that
is
investment in assessing your existing
data structure. So working with one
developer
just actually looking at and deciphering
or reverse engineering the tables they
were given to
include in their LLM pipeline for a text
to SQL example.
Just optimizing some of those tables
actually helped their text to SQL
performance. So it will get better if
they convert it into a graph and use
text to sparkle, but already you're
you're seeing improvement on just
addressing some existing
tech debt.
An organizational commitment to semantic
data cataloging. So everyone needs to
contribute to this. This is something
and it's semantic is also it's important
that it's semantic that you have it
backed up with a
a graph cuz a lot of this
a lot of this representation can't be
captured easily with some other um
some other methods like lineage is best
handled with a graph data structure.
Plan ahead for comprehensive annotations
especially when it comes to
regulatory compliance and AI ready
data rights and access and all of that.
That's becoming an increasingly more
important. So planning ahead for that.
Also languages that's something that um
10 Okay, thanks. Languages that's also
something that is
best handled with
with a graph.
So thinking ahead of
all the things that you need to annotate
up front and if that can be scaled or
expanded as you as you go on.
Enhanced documentation and methods
uh uh enhanced documentation methods and
practices. So, here I wanted to note
I've noticed it's really
important to automate where you can.
And, uh, if anything needs to be updated
to keep it as close to the code as
possible. So, if you, uh,
developers and ontologists were all
switching teams or going to new
organizations, we're inheriting all of
this, uh, data usually and all the stuff
documentation. And, it's really hard to
you might not even know about a Word
document that exists somewhere that was
the original design document you need to
update. Um, or, uh, you know, something
falls flat and isn't updated if it's an
external catalog that isn't
automatically hooked up to any updates
that you're making in your code. So, uh,
documentation as close to code as
possible and any automated processes you
you can put in place to link it to your
data catalog is going to be, uh, the
best way to keep up with updates. That's
the the toughest part.
Uh, avoid lock-in and leverage existing
standards. So, there's a lot of
standards out there that will help you,
uh, model what you need to model or, um,
uh, this mapping CSVW or R2RML, there's
existing things out there. So, don't
create your own and then you're kind of
locked in and, uh, if you want to your
organization wants to change something,
uh, you you don't know how to translate
that into uh, a more open or, uh,
standardized um
uh, way of doing it. And, then
prioritize source data when, uh,
review during your modeling process,
extremely important.
Uh, we forget that, uh, it just takes a
lot longer if we have to
do, uh, reverse engineer everything that
we're we're working with, uh, all alone.
So, it's it's really important to have
access to that source data right from
the uh, design, um, discovery phase.
And uh
uh, yeah, and I wanted to just mention
as part of the AI-ready data is just
following a lot of
a lot from these fair principles. A lot
of companies are doing that. Or five
star open data from Tim Berners-Lee.
I think that's the the key here in order
to make knowledge graph creation faster,
not necessarily the automated processes,
but having our AI ready or having our uh
uh data AI ready is going to help with
that process is my main uh
is the main takeaway here.
So, thank you. Any questions?
Yeah. Um a quick question regarding the
use of
existing domain specific ontologies
When in the process would you propose to
um this kind of existing modeling
methods cuz that would also influence
potentially the conceptual model for
example right?
Absolutely.
Yeah, I would start right at the
discovery phase. uh with the conceptual
model. So, that's part of the the domain
research is is finding existing
vocabularies that that describe your
domain.
Um
uh
yeah, that that that should happen right
away. I think it to be familiar that can
also help uh
the subject matter expert learn more
about what's happening outside of their
own organization. It's just helpful for
everyone to have that very objective
view of the domain to see what else is
how other people are modeling it.
Very important, yeah.
Are you using any um upper level
ontologies to the one that you do when
you make the first uh design?
Like um you know, there's BFO, UFO, all
those like top level ontologies. is
there any use in your work?
Yeah, I've I've used them before, but I
will I will say I'm finding that it's a
lot easier
within an enterprise context to
create your own.
So that it
relates directly to the data that you
have in your in your organization. So
I've tried
you know, using something like FIBO
hasn't always been easy for financial
data
because it is it's awesome and it's it's
it's well constructed but there's so
many nuances with the specific
enterprise data that it's it has been
challenging. So it's more about linking,
making it linkable to these other
ontologies as opposed to using them
principally. So that's my experience,
but I'd love to hear what you
what how you all handle
using domain-specific ontologies
in a very specific context. Yeah.
No, I agree with you and I think it's
good to link it to the upper level if
you if you can. Starting with this for
my personal experience it's been very
rewarding to use those top level to have
the the most
upper abstraction you can.
So you can think about how to put the
different things you are using in your
enterprise into the the different
categories. It's it's good for thinking
to look at those upper level my opinion.
Yeah definitely.
We actually have Jeremy is our next
speaker. So we will have also
panel discussion tomorrow with everyone
from this track. So we can definitely I
already have them in notes. We can
definitely have the top top ontology or
middle ontology as you mentioned in
conversation. So that's that's tomorrow.
Welcome to that. Any other questions?
We're very good on time. Frederick had
uh his questions cut out. Sorry about
that, but now we're on time, so thank
you. And um here, please.
I was interested [clears throat] that
you uh put the the ontology strictly in
the in the the physical
stage. And especially with your
philosophical
background, do you do you see that that
the ontology sits only with in in the
physical stage or
can you see that it can represent things
that are more logical and conceptual?
Well, that's a great question. Um I
think
uh
I'm very pragmatic. And I I I think it's
easier to look at it uh how it actually
fits in
alongside the data
uh itself. That's why I put it in the
the logical um
uh part cuz what I'm noticing is it's uh
ontology is a very
um
I don't fuzzy concept.
And I I don't it is just harder for
developers or someone new to the domain
to really understand what it is. And
then they're kind of left
uh you know, just uh what is this? I
don't know. And never really
understanding it. Uh I'm trying to
put it in the that that category to kind
of demystify it. And it's something very
machine readable and concrete and
related to the data uh is kind of the
the message uh for for that term in this
context. But if we
if we wanted to, you know, kind of have
debates, philosophical debates, then I
would I would go much higher level with
the with the the terminology.
Thank you. Great talk. Um we have quite
a lot of experience with data cataloging
uh in my company. Um I'm just wondering
in your view, what makes a good semantic
data catalog?
Um I think it's uh
having um
uh it links to domain ontologies that
are all uh connected to a what Tony Seal
was talking about this core enterprise
ontology. So, having that domain um
uh representation there in the data
catalog.
Uh I think lineage is extremely
important. I've seen So, having that
capability there that's not always
um even with some semantic tooling
that's not always evident to have the
the lineage feature there. So, I think
that's
um
uh
maybe the most important one I see that
you can't do with other
non-semantic data catalogs.
Um yeah.
Uh I'd like to hear more about uh
your data catalog as well, what you
think too.
Hello.
Um imagine I have to hire an ontology
designer in my team.
What are good questions I should ask at
during the interview or good exercises?
Oh, could you repeat the first part? You
are in an Imagine I have to hire in my
team You have to hire an ontology
designer. So, someone that is going to
do what you would just explain. Ooh,
this is a good topic for tomorrow, as
well. I'd love to know what everyone uh
thinks. Um
Well, that's a good one because I I
think there's
there's so many different
formats for graphs or query languages or
things like that. So, it's really hard
to have a concrete uh
question um for for everyone.
Uh but I
I I've always liked it when it's been
around. So, I'm on that I'm on the
ontologist side. So, I've liked it when
it's been around some kind of um
uh logical puzzle that you have to
solve, some specific question
uh that relates to your domain, so
you're familiar with it and you know,
how would you walk through uh modeling
this
um without, you know, alluding to any
um, kind of representation or anything
like that, but just how
um,
uh, how the ontologist thinks, you know,
I think is is really helpful.
Uh, but I'll come up with more tomorrow.
I'll think about that. Yeah.
We are ahead of time,
which is quite interesting, having
started 15 minutes late. Um, and that's
really thanks to the uh, fantastic
speakers. Maybe um,
but I think we can keep going, yeah? Uh,